zumindestens was bisher auf dem pater
gelaufen ist alles weitere ist bei uns
die co fraktionsvorsitzende der fdp im
bundestag gemeinsam mit alexander
gauland alexander gauland hatte ja
gerade hier eine rede gehalten da hat er
viele vergleiche mit 1989 angestellt
haben wir bei der auch noch erlebt ist
die bundesrepublik wirklich die neue ddr
hat den vergleich angestellt und was man
so beobachten kann dass sich menschen an
den stuhl klammern die in der exekutive
sind wie unsere bundeskanzlerin die sich
über geltendes recht und gesetz
hinwegsetzen und überhaupt gar nicht die
politischen konsequenzen aus dem
desaster was sie angerichtet haben
ziehen das ist dann schon vergleichbar
ich meine aber auch zum beispiel sie
müssen ja jetzt kaum befürchten dass sie
demnächst in stasi gefängnis gelbes
elend nach bautzen deportiert werden und
es gibt auch keinen schießbefehl wenn
man das land verlassen will noch mal die
frage ist dieser vergleich zutreffend
gewesen
ich glaube es ist so zu interpretieren
während den anfängen wir sind wirklich
in einer situation wo politische
entscheidungsträger überhaupt gar nicht
mehr die politischen konsequenzen tragen
auch wenn sie fehler machen und diese
kanzlerin diese kanzlerschaft angela
merkel wird in die geschichtsbücher
eingehen als eine kanzlerin die aus der
bundesrepublik deutschland eine
bananenrepublik gemacht hat wir fallen
überall im internationalen vergleich in
sämtlichen wohlstands indizes was auch
kriminalitätsraten sicherheits raten
anbelangt fallen wir immer weiter zurück
und auch als industriestaat steht sehr
viel auf dem spiel sehen sie einfach mal
die energiewende die sie einfach übers
knie gebrochen hat überhaupt nicht zu
ende gedacht viel zu teuer
ohne das ganze einfach vernünftig auch
durchdacht zu haben
ziehen sie die migrations krisen sehen
sie eben auch die euro rettungspolitik
die aus unserer sicht ja völlig
rechtswidrig ist darum gibt es uns ja
auch aber andere europäische staaten
beneiden uns in unseren wohlstand
das kann man ja so gar nicht
unterschreiben ich meine so mal wird er
immer damit konfrontiert ja die
deutschen hätten vom euro profitiert das
ist mitnichten der fall wenn man sich
vermögen studien anschaut dann ist die
bundesrepublik deutschland schlusslicht
was die vermögenswerte private haushalte
anbelangt so die deutschen sind nicht
reich und das wird ihn auch jeder
arbeitnehmer bestätigen wo zwei leute
arbeiten müssen
in anderen ländern ist das eben nicht so
hin in italien beispielsweise die auch
mit das größte immobilienvermögen haben
das ist dass das zweite ist wer bezahlt
eigentlich unsere exporte in den
euroraum das tun wir selber und zwar
über die tage zwei verpflichtung die
dort eingegangen werden also wir zahlen
unsere exporte in den euroraum das muss
man sich auf der zunge zergehen lassen
die zahlen wir selbst über das tage 2
system
die schulden die quasi andere eu-länder
bei uns haben tage zwei ist das richtig
und so zahlen wir das selber das wird
über das europäische system der
zentralbanken eben auch abgewickelt
das muss man sich mal vorstellen und
insgesamt ist seit der euro-einführung
ist unser exportvolumen in den euroraum
ja kumulativ um zehn prozent
zurückgegangen
der hat sich ja überhaupt gar nicht
vermehrt sowie das immer so auch
dargestellt wird sondern herzlich
kumulativ um zehn prozent ist er zurück
gegangen also dahingehend deutschland
profitiert mitnichten vom euro ganz im
gegenteil alle sparer und rentner und
nachfolgende generation in ganz europa
im übrigen nicht nur in deutschland
werden um ihre ersparnisse gebracht und
das ist eine ganz schlimme entwicklung
alexander gauland hat ja mit seiner rede
hier den parteitag richtig angeheizt
wenn man jetzt mal sieht das gestern auf
dem eu gipfel ja viele forderungen
verabschiedet worden sind die afg schon
lange gestellt hat also sozusagen jetzt
gewissermaßen auch zum teil zumindest
recht bekommt vom eu gipfel ist da nicht
etwas mehr gelassenheit in ihrer partei
an gesagt wir sind ja grundsätzlich
ziemlich gelassen
weil wir auch sehen wie sich die anderen
parteien vor allem auch die fraktionen
im bundestag da gerieren und
dementsprechend sehe ich dass
beispielsweise auch immer als positives
zeichen wenn auch unsere position mit
übernommen werden das ganze hat
natürlich daran dass das
absichtserklärung sind wir sind ja die
partei die auch tatsächlich umsetzen
würde
die anderen parteien tuns nicht also es
kann einfach nur das original sein und
niemals die kopie stichwort
rentenpolitik da können dass streit ins
haus stehen befürchten sie da einen
ordnungspolitischen richtungsstreit die
wirtschaftsliberalen zu denen sie
gehören gegen die die er staatsgläubig
sind was die entwicklung des
rentensystems angeht ich glaube dass die
anträge heute überhaupt gar nicht
besprochen werden letztendlich ist da
jeder jedes parteimitglied auch dazu
eingeladen sich an dem regulären
programm prozess innerhalb der partei
eben auch zu beteiligen und dass das
dort zu diskutieren der bundesparteitag
heute ist dazu nicht das richtige
gremium könnte es ja eine ost west
spaltung in der afg geben in dieser
frage nein das sehe ich nicht ein
weiteres thema ist in die stiftung oder
besser gesagt die politische stiftungen
die sich die afg zulegen will da gibt es
viele die das gar nicht möchte sagen
damit nähern wir uns viel zu sehr den
etablierten parteien an will die afg
nicht erwachsen werden
das wird ja heute hoffentlich diskutiert
da fallen die meinungen in der tat
auseinander
wir sagen ja ganz klar dass das
stiftungswesen insgesamt eingedampft
werden muss dass die zuwendungen die ja
im jahr für 600 millionen euro betragen
das muss man sich mal vorstellen das
wünscht auf steuerzahlerkosten was
seitdem politische stiftung zufließen
dass das massiv reduziert wird dazu
haben wir eben auch ein gesetzesantrag
im bundestag gestellt ja auch abgelehnt
wurde natürlich wieder
und natürlich wollen wir dann
wenn es nicht abgeschafft wird daran
auch partizipieren weil wir
waffengleichheit haben wollen das wird
heute diskutiert ausgang ist offen aber
ich bin ziemlich sicher dass die
delegierten eine vernünftige
entscheidung treffen werden
wir zeigen stärke würden der alfsee
glaube ich so zwischen 60 und 80
millionen zustehen will man doch so
leicht darauf verzichten
das müssen sie die anderen fragen also
ich bin ja ganz ganz klar bei der die
af.de darauf gerne verzichten würde auf
diese 60 bis 80 millionen
die ihnen ja nach dem schlüssel etwa
zustehen würden nochmal ich habe jetzt
die als 60 bis 80 millionen die der afg
nach diesem schlüssel zu stehen würden
für die politischen stiftungen wollen
sie da so leicht drauf verzichten
natürlich nicht darum ist ja auch diese
stiftungsprojekt in den vergangenen
jahren ja schon das läuft ja schon sehr
lang auch ehrenamtlich sag jetzt mal mit
tausenden von ehrenamtlichen stunden
auch vorangetrieben werden und ich halte
das für absolut vital und notwendig dass
die afg eine parteinahe stiftung bekommt
die auf zuwendung bekommen weil
ansonsten werden wir dagegen auch klagen
natürlich alles weitere die co
fraktionsvorsitzende im bundestag
herzlichen dank dass sie dabei und liebe
zuschauer es gibt weiter mit doris
müller und dem weiteren verlauf des
parteitags